ABE HASKINS: Hi, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm going to set my
bottle here, and I'm going
to kick it off at some point.
All right, my name
is Abe Haskins.
I'm a developer engineer on
the Firebase team based out
of San Francisco.
I'm here with
Lauren, who is also
an engineer on
the Firebase team.
And today, we're
going to talk to you
about how to build
an app with Firebase
for go from nothing at a
completed app just using
Firebase.
So if you saw
Lawrence's introduction,
how many people were here
for Lawrence's introduction
to Firebase?
Handful of people.
All right.
Not too Many.
So this Firebase at
a 30,000 foot level.
We see we have 12
products, and those
are tools and that use
to build your product.
So that's your database,
your user authentication,
things like that.
We have our growing tool to
help you grow, get more users,
to engage with those better.
And then we have the earn
section for monetization,
making more money, and making
an actual successful business.
At the core, we have
Firebase Analytics.
Firebase Analytics is
how you know your users.
the core of Firebase
because Firebase is all
about helping your user.
We've built Firebase to
try and help your users.
And at the core of
Firebase, we have
analytics because it relates to
everything about your business
because your business
is all about users.
So, in terms of how
Firebase works as a product,
let's take a step back.
Back in the day, if you were
building something, building
a mobile app, for example,
you have a structure,
something like this.
It might vary, it might be
150 servers instead of one.
Might be a thousand databases
or several different types
of databases.
But it's this general
structure, this what we
call the client-server model.
So we have client
device, in this case,
it's that tablet-looking device.
We have an intermediary
server that you run
and you maintain and have
general control over.
And then behind that,
you have some database
that you've set up, using
Redis or Mongo or whatever.
And that server interacts
with that database,
and then proxies that
data to the client.
And if you're setting
up an app like this,
you're setting it up by writing
a lot of server-side code.
And this code communicates
with your database,
it defines the API that
your client device consumes.
And just by the nature of this,
you already have [INAUDIBLE].
You're not just focusing on
what your users care about,
which is the actual
experience on the device.
They don't really care how
your servers are set up,
they just care that it works.
And you, as the person
running this business,
you have to put a ton of
focus on that middle chunk,
and on the database
chunk, just keep it up
and running just to
keep your company going,
and it dilutes your focus away
from what the users care about.
So when we started
building Firebase,
we realized we could eliminate
a lot of these steps.
You don't have to write custom
code for every database API
endpoint, because they're
all pretty much the same.
They're creating,
reading, they're updating,
they're deleting data.
You don't have to re-implement
an authentication system
every single time you
add Twitter logins,
or you want an email
password login.
That's just silly.
Every single one
of these things has
a ton of concerns
that come with them
and they only grow exponentially
as your company grows.
So something simple
like a password reset
becomes incredibly
complicated when you send out
100,000 of those per day.
So with Firebase, we wanted
it to not only be to get up
and running.
You step out of the door
with a completed great app.
But as you grow, as your
business grows, and to help you
do that, we want
to make sure you
continue to be successful with
the least amount of concern
about the servers, scaling,
and all of those things
that your users
don't care about.
So with that in mind,
let's look at the services,
and remember a bit
about what these are.
So to develop, like I said,
the real-time database
is the way to synchronize
and store data,
so it's an alternative to
a traditional database.
But unlike a
traditional database,
you're not writing a server
that interacts with Firebase.
You interact with
the Firebase database
directly from your client.
So if you're writing an iOS code
or you're writing Android code,
you import our SDK, you point
it at the real-time database,
and you start
reading and writing.
Similar with authentication.
If you want to log in
via email password,
you're not setting
up an endpoint
that has a database behind it.
You're just saying, I want
to log in on your client.
And we run all the servers,
we maintain everything,
so you just get a
secure user login
system that'll work for you.
And this is every
single product.
I'm not going to
go through them now
if you want to know more about
them, hit up the documentation
or go ask Lawrence,
who is at the booth.
He will tell you in detail
about every single one
of these products.
But this is the general
pattern It's taking something
that you used to have to
writer server code for, spend
a bunch of effort, spend a
bunch of operational costs,
keeping your servers
up and running.
We just simplified
it down and give you
client side,
[INAUDIBLE] side, that
feels natural in the
language of your choice
to consume these features.
So, back to our actual
goal here today.
We want to go and build a
completed app just using
Firebase.
And since it's Firebase, that
means no server side code.
We leverage all the
cool powers of the Cloud
and we end up with something
that is actually usable
and shipped to our users.
And any time you want
to build anything,
you pretty much have to
start out with an idea.
So I do this game where I write
down a bunch of different words
that I know.
In this case I don't
know if these words
because I don't
speak that language.
But, if I did speak this
language, I would go
and I would circle
some of these and I'd
pick just a few random
ones that I like.
So I could make a
social photo chat.
And that sounds good.
So this idea is
just an experiment.
This is something I really
like about Firebase.
We can go, we can pick
some random words,
and we can start putting
it together into something
very quickly.
It's good for prototyping
and getting up and running.
Like I said, we want it to
be quick, to get it building.
And then once you've
built something,
for it to be successful.
Let's take this idea
and see what we can do.
So imagine we have a user.
We have this friendly fellow
who is very happy to be looking
at his phone, and we have
these three concepts,
we want to make
some sort of chat.
We want it to interact
with his friend
and we want to be
able to upload photos.
So let's just build
a chat experience.
Something where a user can
sign in with some provider
that they like, maybe
Twitter login, Google
login, something like that.
They can find their
friends and chat with them.
And then they can send
photos back and forth.
This is a simple idea,
yes, but implementing
this in a traditional
kind of server model
is incredibly complicated.
If you've ever
written any networking
code, any socket code to deal
with real-time communication,
that is a huge, huge, taking on.
It is such a big problem.
If you've ever dealt
with [INAUDIBLE],
this is something that seems so
simple, taking some binary data
and storing it.
But there is so many
edge cases and issues,
but Firebase solves
all of these.
So this entire problem can be
solved in the next 20 minutes
or so.
And to give you some idea of
what we're trying to make,
this is what it's going
to end up looking like.
It's called FriendlyChat.
It's going to let us to
send messages, upload
pictures, everything like that.
This is our goal, what
we're aspiring to.
Next step, we need
to pick a platform.
We've got an idea, now we've
got to figure out how are we
going to distribute this?
We have a lot of platforms
in Firebase that we support.
In fact, this isn't
even all of them.
This is all the first
class ones that we
say are highest
quality SDKs that we
have documentation about.
But we have some
other beta SDKs,
like Unity for C++ if you're
interested in development.
But here we have Android,
iOS, C++, and Web.
Today we're going to
focus just on Web.
And the reason I'm doing this
is because the code snippets
are a little shorter.
There's a lot more boiler
plate to get an Android up
and running.
But Firebase works everywhere.
So whatever we're
learning and doing today,
changing it to work in
iOS will be just a matter
of inputting the iOS
SDK and changing it
to the right type of code.
All the features,
all the functionality
is there on Android,
iOS, Web, etc.
So just because we're
talking about JavaScript,
don't think that you have to
be building something in Web
to be doing this.
It's also worth
noting that if you're
building something
cross-platform,
you're building an iOS app.
And an Android app,
that's going to work
great with Firebase
because the same cloud
services available to you
in one are available to you
in the other.
So let's actually
write some code.
The first step to
actually building an app
is writing code generally.
I'm sure someone has
built an app without code,
but I don't do that.
So we need to include
in this library.
And this is the only snippet
in here that is cross-platform.
And I want to do
is to demonstrate
that, in each environment,
although the code is similar,
it feels natural
in it environment.
So in iOS, we include
a Firebase core,
which is that analytics core
plus another core Firebase
aspect, and we call
up for app configure
to say, hey, set this up.
In Android, there's even code.
We call it in our Gradle
file this plug-in,
that's something for it.
And in Web, we just
include JavaScript
to call initialize app.
As you can see, they're
all slightly different
because they feel natural
in the environment
that we're writing this code
in, but the functionality
in each environment
will be the same.
Now that we've
looked at this, we
have our idea, a
social photo chat.
And we know we're
using Firebase and we
know we're focusing on Web.
And we're going to say,
what do we want to use here?
And this is an
overwhelming slide.
There isn't a lot of
functionality here.
We don't need all
of it for our app.
We need to pick and choose.
And this is one of the
great things about Firebase.
Every feature on
here works alone.
It can stand alone, it
can be useful alone.
When you get more and more power
with every one you include.
So by mixing and matching two
or three of these features,
we're going to get a really
rich experience for our user.
But if you only
want dynamic links,
you only want crash
reporting, you
can always just do that, too.
So in this case, we're going
to focus on these four Firebase
features.
Firebase Authentication because
we need a way for people
to be able to log in.
We want them to
have authentication,
so this is obvious.
And we use Firebase
Storage to deal
with offloading and
securing our uploaded files.
We use Firebase
Realtime Databases
to deal with synchronizing
of messages between users
and between devices.
And then we'll use
Firebase Cloud Messaging
to unloading them with they
don't have the app open.
Let's talk about
Firebase Authentication.
LAUREN LONG: All right.
Thank you.
So as Abe mentioned, you're
building a social chatting
photo app today.
And first off, you want a way
for users to log into the app.
You want to do this so that
we can display their username
to themselves and to the people
that they are chatting with.
We also want this for
security purposes,
to ensure that me,
as a user, can only
write to the part of the
database that contains
my messages, not to the
part of the database that
contains Abe's messages.
So I don't know how many of you
have built an authentication
system from scratch before.
I've done this recently
and it was a huge headache.
So I was just building a
simple email password login
for an app I was creating.
And I had to learn
about a lot of things,
such as how to set cookies
when someone logs in,
how to have those cookies expire
after a certain amount of time,
revoke the cookies
when they log out.
I had this issue where
a lot of my users
couldn't log in for some reason.
And after a lot of
debugging, I discovered
it's because some of them
wrote capital letters
in their emails.
And that caused a
lot of problems.
So I then had to sanitize
the entire database,
lower case, everything,
removes spaces
at the beginning
and the end emails.
A lot of issues I didn't foresee
that ended up taking up my time
and preventing me
from working on things
that were really interesting.
So with Firebase,
we make something
like authentication
really simple
to just put right into your app.
So the things that we support,
this first email and password
authentication.
Second, we can do
custom authentication.
So this says that if you
want to use something
like a phone number plus
password authentication,
you can build that
integration yourself.
Or if you want to
use a provider we
don't currently work
with, such as WeChat or QQ
for people to be able to sign
in using those credentials.
We also have built-in
providers that you
can put into your app that are
commonly used around the world.
Things such as Twitter,
Facebook, and Google.
If someone has one
of those accounts,
they can sign into your app.
So the benefits of using
Firebase authentication,
instead of building
your own, is taking
care of a lot of the edge
cases I told you about.
But also we make it very
easy to have the UI.
So this site, you
see here a list
of buttons where people can
pick how they want to log in.
You can put this into your app
with just one line of code.
Secondly, we make password
resets really easy.
So this is something when I
was building my authentication
system, didn't consider at all.
And then I was getting users
calling me, saying, hey,
I forgot my password.
And then I had to
go into my database,
make sure I delete
their current record,
send them an email with a
link to reset their password,
a real pain.
And if you're
building an app that
has thousands,
tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands
of users, you're
going to be getting a
lot of these password
resets every single day.
And something that should be
really simple like sending
an email with a
password or reset link
actually becomes
really complicated.
Because when you're
sending that many e-mails,
you're going to be
caught by spam filters,
your e-mails won't go
through, or they'll
be very late in arriving
in your users' inbox,
making the experience
very frustrating.
So with Firebase authentication,
you can do password reset out.
We even have email templates
you can use and modify
to have your own branding.
And we make this whole process
easy and secure to your users.
Another thing that we do
that is anonymous accounts.
So let's say you're
building a shopping app
and someone might
just be trying it out
and they browse around
for about half an hour.
They might put some
things in their cart.
And then they decide to buy it.
And that point, you would ask
them to create an account.
But you don't want them to lose
all the data they previously
had.
You don't want them to have
to go pick those items again
and put them in the cart again.
With anonymous accounts, even
when someone doesn't sign in,
you create and
account for them right
when they are on your webpage.
And when they do
create a real account,
you can link that
information and nothing
gets lost in the process.
So let's see how
we do this in code.
As Abe mentioned, we already
initialized a Firebase
instance.
And next we align three
call Firebase.auth.
This gives us an instance
of the authentication
service of Firebase.
And once that, there is a
lot of different functions
and attributes that
we have access to.
So let's say you have a web
form, where someone has filled
out their email
and their password
and you store those variables.
You have an email and
a password variable.
You want to now check to see
if their password is correct.
So you call this function
online [INAUDIBLE], sign
in with email and password,
provide it with these two
parameters, and
this will tell you
if it is a user that
has already signed up
and if their
password is correct.
This function returns a promise.
So if you have used
promises before, it's
a way to handle asynchronous
code in JavaScript,
it is an alternative
to a callback.
And with a promise, you get
a then function and a catch
function.
So in the then function,
this is the success case.
When the password
is the correct one,
you get, in the function
here, a result, which
represents that sign-in user.
And result.user
gives you everything
that Firebase
authentication knows
about that user, including
the universal ID, their email,
their password, maybe a
picture associated with them.
And you can store that in the
user variables to use later.
And let's say they type
in the wrong password,
the catch function
catches that error
and we have code and
a message that you
can choose to display to
the user, if you would like.
Let's see how we do this with
one of our existing providers.
We're using Google
Sign In in this case,
so this is someone that
has a Google account
and they want to use that
to sign in to your app,
instead of creating
an additional account
and another password just
to remember for your app.
So here in line 4,
they create an instance
of a Google auth provider.
So you can do this
not only with Google,
but also our other providers,
such as Twitter and Facebook,
and you simply place
Google with those names.
Next, they call the sign in with
pop up function on the Firebase
auth service, and
pass in the parameter
that we just is initialized.
So what this does is
it creates a pop up
that will have UI asking
for their Google credential.
And all this then goes to Google
servers, not your servers.
So you don't have to worry about
security and storing users'
data or [INAUDIBLE] password
to their Google account.
And once they type
in their credentials,
the function again
returns a promise
with a then and a catch.
And in [INAUDIBLE], you
get the success case,
you get the user object with
all the information you need.
And if it fails, an
error code and message
that you can choose to display
to the user if you like.
Now let's talk about how you
do custom authentication.
So this is useful if you
are, like I mentioned,
trying to integrate with
a third party provider
we haven't supported yet,
such as WeChat or QQ,
or if you would like to
work with an existing auth
system you already have
created for your app.
So you call the sign in with
custom, token, function.
Pass a function that was
created on your server,
either through a third party
or your own custom auth flow.
And in the success
case, you would
have the same user
object you had earlier
And the failure case would
have a message that you
would display to the user.
So now we figured out how
to get someone to sign in.
I just wanted to know
that we here only
looked at how to sign in.
But for someone to sign
up is a very similar flow,
and the code looks identical.
You just have to replace
the function names.
So instead of sign
in with custom auth,
it would be something like
sign up in custom auth.
Next, we're going to look
at how to let users upload
the photos once
they've signed in,
and Abe will chat
with you about that.
ABE HASKINS: So we're going to
talk about Firebase Storage.
Firebase Storage is the
solution for dealing
with uploading files Once
the user has authenticated,
we want to give them a way to
upload images, in this case.
But in many cases,
this could be videos,
it could be documents,
PDFs, anything.
This is a general solution to
dealing with uploading files.
Firebase storage is
really great because it's
backed by a very powerful
system for storing files.
And not only storing them,
but also securing them.
You can know for
sure that a user who
uploaded a file to their
folder on Firebase storage
will only have access
to that folder,
and no one else can read
or write to their folder.
You can restrict how big
a file they can upload,
you can check and make sure
they have the right MIME type
so you know they're
only uploading
the right type of file.
You have a lot of options
and a lot of control here.
So you get started
with this in HTML.
We have two elements which
make up our simple upload form.
We have the input type of file.
So that's where they'll
actually select the file.
We'll have a button
that just says Upload.
And that's all we need.
Once we get into JavaScript, we
just have some boilerplate here
to select those two inputs.
So the input file is
that type file input,
and the button Submit
is our Submit button.
The we have the Add
Event Click Listener.
Again, this is just
normal JavaScript.
This is not anything
special about Firebase.
Once we get down
into this part, we
get into all the
magic of Firebase.
First thing we
want to do is draft
the input file [INAUDIBLE].
So this will be the first file
that the user has selected.
Sometimes they can
upload multiple files
if they have
multifileselect enabled.
But in this case, we allow that.
After that, we
have the reference
to the Firebase
storage location.
So Firebase storage
[INAUDIBLE] upload.jpeg.
So we're saying that we want
to upload this to upload.jpeg.
It's just a matter
of what the file is
that the person is uploading.
If it is named HelloWorld123, it
will be uploaded to upload.jpeg
And then below,
we'll do [INAUDIBLE].
And this is the actual
call to upload the file.
This is all it takes to store
that file the user has selected
on our server.
Direct output file is a file
that the input has specified.
And then with that
same comments function,
we check to make
sure it's successful,
and then we log out, upload it.
And then below here, we've
assigned the download URL
to this variable
[INAUDIBLE] URL.
In this case, a download
URL is literally just
a URL to the image.
We could embed this
in an image tag,
we could download it, save it
to the hard drive, whatever
we want to do.
In this case, we're just
storing it as a variable
so we can later append it
to a message to send off.
Next, we're going to talk
about the Firebase database.
Lauren?
LAUREN LONG: So let's think
about what we've done so far.
We made it available for the
user to sign into the app.
We then allow them
to upload a photo.
Now let's allow them to chat.
So Firebase Database is our
solution for storing data,
and it's a very powerful one.
It is a JSON-based
database, so if you've
worked with JSON
before, anything
that you can encode
in JSON, you can
store within Firebase Storage.
It is key value store, so it's
not an SQL-based database,
it is a null
relational database.
The very powerful thing
about Firebase Database
is how it's real time.
What this means is any
time one of your users
puts something into the
database, all the other users
that [INAUDIBLE] that
same database will
get that changed instantly.
No one needs to refresh their
page for this to happen.
And this happens
within milliseconds.
We also offer a really
great offline support.
So if I'm typing a message
and my connectivity goes out
because my Wi-Fi has stopped
working for some reason,
then the chat I
sent gets cued up.
And when I'm online again,
it gets sent to the database.
Now this feature is
really key if you're
trying to develop for
a market like India,
where a lot of people
have smartphones,
but good connectivity
is hard to find.
So a lot of people have
very spotty networks
and spotty Wi-Fi.
This is how it would
store something.
So this is what we're going
to use today for our chat app.
As you can see, it is JSON.
It is essentially
a tree of values,
so we store everything in
this top level chats node.
And within chats, we
have different chat IDs
representing chat rooms.
So today in our chat room,
we've got two messages so far.
Each message has it own ID.
And in the content
of that message,
we have a UID, which
stands for User ID.
This associate that message
with the user that sent it.
We're also storing the content
of that message in plain text.
And when someone
types in something,
it goes to the Firebase
database in the Cloud.
It then propagates to
every other device that's
connected to that database.
So this could be
if a user is using
your app on both their phone
and computer at the same time.
This could be people that
are using the same app.
Not that user, but other people
that are in that chat room,
trying to see what
messages are being sent.
The synchronization
happens very fast.
And it does not require
any of the users
to refresh their page.
So this is very powerful.
This makes single page
apps really easy to build,
this makes the experience
really magical and delightful
for your users.
And this is something that
would normally be very hard
for you to build by yourself.
But today, as you'll see
in the next few slides,
it just takes a
few lines of code.
So here we get an instance
of the Firebase Database
on Line 1.
Similar to how we set
up the auth in storage.
We just call Firebase.databse.
Next, we actually
want a reference
to the place in the
database that we want
to store in the next message.
So as you remember from our
diagram that we went over,
we have everything
stored inside chats,
and we have a chat
ID for chat room.
So we get a reference
to the place
in the database
with the path chats
slash the ID that
we're on right now.
And here in Line 4, we
have a helper function
called send chat app.
And this function is called
whenever someone types
in a message and clicks
on the Submit button.
So when they've don that, we
call a function on the chat ref
called push.
And we give push the
content of what we
want to store in the database.
So this is the user ID,
we sent the message,
and the message that
they just wrote.
Now there's other functions
you can call on chat reference,
such as set.
And the difference between
these two functions
is that set is if you
know the exact path
to that place in the database,
whereas push is useful
when you're adding
something to a list.
And push also automatically
gives that new item
a unique ID.
So you don't have to
worry about setting,
you don't need to figure
out how to randomize an ID
and ensuring that they are
unique with each new message
that you are storing.
So we've pushed it so from the
lines that are highlighted,
this is all the code
we would need to write
something the in the database.
Very simple.
Next, we want to
then make sure we
know when someone
has typed a message,
and then display
that to the user.
So Line 12 to 14 shows
us how we do that.
So in the same chat ref
that we just wrote to,
we add a listener
called child added.
And give it a handler.
So child added
listens to the event
where something
new has been added
to that list of chat messages.
So if either me or someone
that I'm chatting to
has wrote to the database,
this function will fire.
And it will fire with a
parameter called snapshot,
which contains everything
we need to know about
that new database write event.
So in this case, we can
call snapshot.val on Line 13
to get us the content that
was sent to the database.
We then have another function
called display chat message,
which we didn't show you here.
But this would just be a message
for you to actually display it
in the HTML.
So check it out.
This is all the code we
have to achieve a real time
synchronization of messages
across multiple devices
in milliseconds.
And another neat
thing we can do here
is connect storage
and database together.
So when Abe went
over the storage
part of the
presentation, you might
remember that we get back
a URL that we then use
to download that image again.
So if someone has sent an
image along with their message,
we can write that URL
within the database.
So when we display
that message again,
we not only display the
message that they sent,
we also display the
image that they uploaded.
So this is how you
connect together
the storage and the database.
So now that we've given the user
the ability to sign in, write
a message, upload
a photo, we want
to notify them when they
want to know something
about what's happening.
ABE HASKINS: So if we
want to notify someone
when they're online, when
they have the app open
when it's in the foreground,
this is pretty easy.
All we have to do
is say, nothing.
We just did it.
We wrote the code already.
We wrote it with the
real time database.
That's going to synchronize
every message that
comes on when the app is open.
But if they get a message
when they're offline,
my code's not going
to be running, is it?
That code's been shut off,
the app has been killed,
they don't have to tap open.
They will not get any
type of notification.
This is where Firebase
Cloud Messaging comes in.
So Firebase Cloud Messaging
is a generic push notification
solution.
So it can push to mobile
devices like Android and iOS.
It can push to web
browsers, which
is what we'll be doing here.
You have a lot of options for
sending alerts to users who
are not currently in your app.
And you can even use it
for in-app notifications
if you'd like.
But in this case, we're
mostly focusing on the use of,
I'm not in your app right now,
but somebody sent me a message
and I want to know about it.
So setting this
up is pretty easy,
just like all the other
code we looked at.
We can start it with
a messaging instance,
so we get Firebase.messaging.
And then we call
messaging.getToken.
And this is going to
get us a unique ID
token that is generally
set to refer to a device.
In this instance, it actually
refers to a browser instance.
But the important part
is that it is a machine,
it is this user on this machine.
Once we have this ID token
on our server, we can go
and we can send any given push
ID for any given push we want.
So we can say, hey,
your friend came online.
Hey, you got a new message.
Hey, you know, you're
billing expired.
Anything like that we want to
do, we can do with this token.
That's why when we
successfully get this token,
we send it to our server.
And this function
isn't shown here,
but in actuality, this code
would send to the real time
database probably, and we would
have an announcement saying,
you logged in with
Twitter with this UID,
and associate it with that
user ID this push token.
Then, if for some
reason we weren't
able to get the token, we
request permissions, we set up
a dialogue for you
that says, hey,
you need to do this so we
can have push notifications.
And then that can allow it
to successfully get tokens.
Actually, getting that
token is really easy.
And then, like I said,
storing it, very easy.
And then consuming that,
sending push notifications
to this specific
user, very simple.
If we want to
catch that message.
If we don't want to
catch the message,
and we just want push
notifications to show up,
so they pop up on the top
of the screen and it says,
hey, you got a new message, we
don't have to write any code.
That's the default functionality
of Firebase Cloud messaging.
So if I want that, we're good.
We actually want to go
a little beyond that
and customize it a little bit.
So if I have the app open
and I'm chatting to Lauren,
I don't want to know when I
got the message from Lauren
in the form of a
push notification,
because I already
have the app open.
That would be really annoying.
Every time she
sends me a message,
I'm just getting
the same push twice,
and that would be really weird.
So what we do here is we say
messaging.onMessage and put
on this callback and we say
any time I get a message,
if I have the app open, this
code is going to catch it,
and it won't show that
actual push modification
in the browser.
If we want to, in our chat
app, we can use this as a call
to action and say,
change the channel chat
to be focused on Lauren.
Or wiggle her icon or
something like that to say,
hey, you got a message.
But we don't have to show
the native push notification
you UI if we don't want to.
And that's what this
is doing over here.
So we are cheating
a little bit here.
I'll admit there
is some server side
code that would generally be
used with this to complete
this example.
But Lawrence is giving a
Firebase Cloud messaging
and Firebase notifications
talk right after this.
So if you have a lot of
interest in push notifications,
definitely go to
that talk and he
will explain in very
good detail everything
about implementing this.
So we have pretty much completed
our app with these four
Firebase features.
We put these into a chart that
kind of map the user's flow.
The first thing they
do is say log in
with Firebase authentication.
And they're logged in
and we know who they are.
Then they go to
take their picture,
and we upload that
to Firebase storage.
And then as soon
as they do that,
we use Firebase Cloud
Messaging and Firebase
database to send that
out to all their friends.
And we have a
complete experience.
This is everything you
need to build an app.
So let's look at what
we actually made here,
one you take this an add
a little but of polish.
We have this original
app that we looked at.
And if we step through this,
we have the Sign In button.
We hit Sign In.
We get that beautiful screen
of all the different provider
options you can log in with.
In this case, we would
sign in with Google,
but any of these
providers are provided.
And if you want to add
custom ones, like we said,
WeChat or QQ or any
of these options,
you can add those as Firebase
authentication login options.
After we've logged in, we will
change our welcome message
to say, hey, welcome, Ben.
Welcome to our hashtag
#golang chat room.
And the previous messages
that have already been sent
will be displayed to that.
And this is something really
interesting about the real time
database that is often
kind of unexpected.
It's a problem that
you don't really
realize you have until you get
really far into development,
which is that if we were
normally building a [INAUDIBLE]
with sockets and all
of that painful stuff,
we have to write a
bunch of code just
to send users who just connected
all the historical messages.
So Firebase is super simple.
We can go in and we can
say, give us every message.
And that's what
we did when we did
that child added [INAUDIBLE].
So a new user entering this
chat will automatically
be caught up with every
previous message sent.
Or if you change the
code a little bit,
they might get the
last 10 messages
or the last five or whatever.
So you don't have to
worry about saying, oh,
are they going to get
previous messages?
Firebase takes care
of that for you.
So let's actually send
a chat and look at this.
Imagine we have another user,
this is one is named James.
And he's somewhere
across the world from Ben
and he's looking to chat.
And Ben decides to
write a message.
He doesn't really like that
we have a golang chat room,
but not a C sharp chat room.
So he decides to
write that in for us.
And he sends this message.
No as soon as he sends it,
imagine no time has passed.
Mere milliseconds have passed.
James has not gotten
an update yet.
Nothing has happened,
but over the next 10,
20, 30 milliseconds, we're going
to see that Firebase match.
It's going to get
sent out to the Cloud
and synchronized back down.
And before James can blink,
probably literally before you
can blink, that'll be
synchronized back to him,
and he can get that message.
And we do a little
cool client side
logic to say on this
one it's sent by you
and this one is sent by Ben, so
we're looking at the messages
as they come in,
customizing UI a little bit.
But this is all super
straightforward,
and if you want the complete
code for an example,
just like this, we have
them available on GitHub.
We have full chat
applications where
you can upload pictures
and invite people and chat
with people, all
built on Firebase
with little to no server
side code available
online right now,
if you're interested
in building [INAUDIBLE]
And this is the important
part about Firebase.
We just built this with no
server side [INAUDIBLE].
We built an entire chat
experience just using Firebase.
So you can imagine
if we take this
and we ship it out to
our users, you will never
get a call in the middle of
the night that says, hey,
your chat is down.
Because Firebase is handling it.
And if something does happen,
if some outage does happen,
we have a literal squad
of folks whose only
job is to make sure
things get resolved.
You won't be waking
up, you won't
be getting disturbed
during dinner
because your app is down.
This is a wonderful
thing about Firebase,
is once you've built this,
it's ready and it's out there
and you don't have
to be concerned
with all those ongoing
maintenance issues.
You've just got a chat that
works, and works really,
really well.
So that's trying it.
Let's ship it.
Let's actually get
this into production
and see how hard it is
to get this to our users.
LAUREN LONG: So we're
are going to be talking
about another product,
a fifth one actually,
called Firebase Hosting.
So Hosting is how you
get from your test app
to an app that is
available across the world.
And normally if you want
to get something out
onto the internet, you
have to buy a domain,
have to set up
DNS, you might have
to wait about 24 hours
for it to propagate,
and then maybe you can test it.
If you want an SSL certificate,
that takes extra effort.
You have to activate it and
integrate it with your website.
With Firebase, we give
you very simple commands
you can use right
within your terminal.
So Firebase init is how you
initialize a Firebase project
before you start developing.
Firebase Serve opens up a
local port and a local server
that you can use
to test your app.
The really cool thing
about Firebase Serve
is, even though
it's a local host,
it talks to your real database
and your real storage packet
so you can test all those
things while you're developing.
And when you're
ready for your app
to be logged into
the real world,
all you do is Firebase
deploy in your terminal,
and you get it out
on the internet.
We give you a domain--
your app ID dot firebaseapp.com.
But if you would like to
connect a custom domain,
you can do that as well.
So we just shipped it.
ABE HASKINS: Yeah.
That was incredibly
easy, compared
to any other solution for
shipping a product like this.
Firebase hosting
is absurdly simple.
And what I love about
our Firebase Hosting,
I love all of Firebase,
but I especially
love Firebase Hosting
because of how it came about.
We did this thing at worked
called Experiment Week,
and in Experiment Week, we said,
hey build something useful.
Like we always have roadmaps
where we're planning years
ahead, but if we want to
take a week to just try
to build something that
we think might be cool,
we don't know it's going
to be useful [INAUDIBLE]
But we wanted to take that week
and try And one week, somebody
said, you know what I can't do?
I can't find a place
to put my HTML.
That sounded like
a silly question
because there are other
options out there,
but they didn't
fill these needs.
They weren't fast enough,
they weren't performant.
So one of our engineers, Chris,
he went out and he spent a week
and built a prototype of
Firebase Hosting just for fun.
And what came out
of that was one
of the coolest
Firebase products.
All of Firebase hosting grew
out of that one week experiment.
And I think this is my
favorite part about Firebase,
and not only our
internal culture,
but what we enable people
to do, is to experiment.
When you don't have to think
about setting authentication
and you don't have to think
about how to synchronize data
in real time,you don't have
to have to think about all
of these things.
You get an entire
new realm of ideas
you can implement in a weekend
or you can implement in a week,
and you can pitch to someone.
You just get so
many more options,
and so this is what I encourage
you to go do is try this.
Go be like Firebase
and experiment,
play around, and see
what comes out of it.
You never know what
little idea that Firebase
enables you to do.
It's going to become the
next billion dollar business
because you really can just
do so much more than you've
ever [INAUDIBLE]
So with that, I want
to send you back
to this slide of
the 15 products.
Now that we have a little
more context, hopefully
you have some idea about
which ones might interest you.
Like I said, if you don't
want to use all of them,
you don't have to.
If you want to try Analytics
next to your existing solution,
you can do that, too.
You have a ton of choices
and a ton of freedom here.
We don't want to limit
what you want to build.
You can always check
under documentation
for fine-grained details
on firebase.google.cn,
newly launched.
I believe it was launched today,
so definitely check that out.
And one aside, if you're
interested in open source code,
if you want to see what
it's like to build stuff
inside Google, how we do things,
what it's like to be a Firebase
developer, we have 90
open source projects
at Firebase alone.
Not even the rest of Google.
If you want to come
check us out, see
what Lauren's working
on day-to-day,
there's a ton of open source.
You can see our
command line post.
See how we wrote that.
You can see our framework,
see how we wrote those.
That's all available
online, open source,
for you to check out
and build off of.
Thank you so much.
It was great talking to you.
[APPLAUSE]
With that, we're
going to take a couple
questions, so anyone
who has questions,
feel free to yell them out.
And if you have to be
going, that's fine, too.
We have just a couple
of minutes for questions
if anyone has anything
super-pressing.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]